what's going on there reject nation greg
and john with the wand today we just got
out of watching fantastic beasts and the
secrets of dumbledore so many secrets
all these a couple of a couple of
secrets couple secrets mostly things we
knew already i was like we going to see
dumbledore in in a bad light
not really no they always teetered they
played a little safe they mention it a
lot of you guys might know this
we were not fans of the crimes of
grindelwald no no no no no sir first
thing harry potter movie i actively
disliked i really don't like that film
and here's the first thing i'll tell you
guys it is so much better than the
crimes of grindelwald like light years
better i can actually tell you what the
plot of this movie is which is already
in itself a significant improvement over
the last film so yeah if you haven't
seen the trailers jude law playing
dumbledore because of a blood pact that
he made with grindelwald back in the day
when they was gay lovers oh my god oh my
god jk exploring the gay stuff
i think they still are yeah they're
still gay they don't do they stop it
they don't they they
any longer
when you find out that you know
grindelwald is actually transgender in
this movement
that's never gonna happen
trans rights harry potter movie is here
see that anyways so dumbledore and
listen to help of newt scamander they
assemble a team to basically work
together to figure out a way to take
down grindelwald the enemy played by
mads mikkelsen this time not colin
farrell not johnny depp nads mickelson
that is the plot of the movie while
there's some secrets to uncover
throughout they keep it pretty
streamlined and focused now does that
mean it's a good movie
just because it's better than the last
one
kind of uh yeah no it's definite
improvement because of how much i didn't
like the last one i was watching this
with not as much of an open mind in the
first half hour i did find myself being
like a little overly critical when i
didn't need to be then when i caught
myself i was just asking myself like
okay how am i really responding to this
film overall in the end i would say like
i actually enjoyed it because here's the
honest to god truth
we saw it at a different theater but
we weren't a lot of film in there nope
so we drove to a different theater
authenticity baby how the sausage is
made but we do our reviews it defeaters
no one's gonna care if it's not
authentic in the car right over to this
other theater i was like oh yeah we need
to talk about this movie
i haven't thought about it one video i
do have some pretty clear problems that
i'll save for a little bit later but
yeah in the end of it all i still prefer
the first fantastic beasts movie i know
some are saying this one's better
especially because it's darker i don't
agree with that assessment for this
particular installment and it doesn't
quite capture the magic of what you
would want even though there's a lot of
magic it doesn't elicit the emotion of
feeling wonder and magic this film is
definitely aiming for it's fine a little
bit forgettable but fine
yeah it falls squarely in the middle of
the fantastic beast films for me and i
felt a lot of similar things i came in
certainly hoping that it would be a
better experience than crimes of
grindelwald and it it is but it doesn't
quite capture the cohesive magic of the
first movie even though there are
aspects of the secrets of dumbledore
that i do kind of like the most out of
the franchise but yeah overall it's not
consistent enough or as important and
momentous as it wants to be ultimately
it was kind of a middling but pleasant
experience yeah especially by the end of
it it felt a little like perfunctory i
thought they could have wrapped this
whole story up let's talk about mads
mikkelsen all right it was really weird
experience but halfway through the film
john stood up and said justice for jesus
that's right it's happening today okay
mads mikkelsen i would say he is the
best this is like the weird thing about
this franchise i would say he's the best
grindelwald we've had thus far easily
the best grindelwald it feels like he
was always there yeah no he lives in it
i feel like he actually understood like
the harry potter world very well and
knew everything of what he was dealing
with and talking about you know he
really feels lived in at the same time
he didn't quite leave as strong of an
impression as one would actually hope
and this is probably incredibly
subjective for me myself so i'm curious
here what you have to say i love mads
mickelson the performer like i've seen
all of hannibal he's fantastic and
that's
fantastic he's fantastic in that show as
well brilliant i hope that gets picked
up for a season four what he did here
was exactly what you'd expect but
nothing more he's really enjoyable he
can be intimidating but it's like he
doesn't do anything that really goes
beyond anything you just expect out of
him do you kind of get what i mean by
that yeah i do and i think it's more of
a scripting issue than anything because
yeah he does mainly the issues with
these films
and it's like he does bring that
presence and he does bring that
malevolent force who many people would
follow and dedicate their lives to all
that's great i do feel like the
portrayal of his character is hurt a bit
by the fact that we don't really get any
flashbacks or any you know past
experiences to either show the
connection in a deeper way between him
and dumbledore or to show his true
villainy i mean there's a couple things
in this movie he does that are pretty
cruel but i don't know it seems like
they want to build up another threat
that is voldemort level important and
earth-shattering and i don't feel like
they did the leg work to get there they
just kind of told you what his
importance is and went from there to the
present like we've heard world
domination villain like countless times
there's no longer an effect anymore in
films unless there's something more
specific explored and yeah i would agree
with that there's like two really
pivotal important scenes one at the
beginning and one at the very end with
uh dumbledore and grindelwald that i
think are really strong scenes and it's
really cool to see those actors together
here's the thing i i might as well just
hop into it because like ideally you
want to do is like talk about the good
things i don't really want to talk too
much about them right like jacob
kowalski he's the star of this all right
once again he's the best part of this
and the real heart and these movies
should be about him i don't care what
anyone says because he is amazing in
here and there's also this new character
what's her name hicks hicks she's great
she's another character like you kind of
wish they did more with her yet she is
one of the actors i would say that when
she's on screen her presence really
elevates the material i think she is
truly truly wonderful in this film those
two are the standouts for me yeah she's
one of the few characters that actually
elevates the movie to the level of
whimsy and warmth that you expect a
harry potter movie to have at some point
they pair her and jacob together quite a
bit in this film and they're so good
together jude law does as good of a job
as you'd expect carrying over from
crimes of grindelwald and the effects
and the production design are as amazing
as you would expect walking into this
film and a good job making newt's
expertise in the fantastic beasts feel
like a real part of it the finale was
cool i like the finale there's some good
visual sequences in here it's just when
it's not doing that it's not that
interesting i think that's the problem
this movie should be just as interesting
even when it's not doing big visual
stuff because in any harry potter movie
like everywhere you go that's not muggle
world is interesting yeah while i think
this film is better paced and better
structured than crimes of grindelwald
the movie doesn't really do enough to
get you to truly care about the
characters a because it's a prequel it
suffers so much from the prequel
syndromes by taking away focus from your
new characters like newt scamander and
jacob and putting it onto existing
characters like dumbledore and then
grindelwald who half this plot is
grindelwald being like we got to kill
dumbledore let's send ezra miller after
him
it's impossible for me to buy the stakes
like i know he's going to live and then
with grindelwald i know he's going to
lose
the bottom line so i don't fear for any
of them so the stakes are just not felt
and you might be saying like well then
how do you enjoy any prequel well the
key to that is the intimate
characterization that you do with these
individuals that's why something like
x-men first class can still work because
of the fact you get these new intimate
details you didn't explore before while
you get some facts about grindelwald
some
facts about dumbledore the actual
exploration of it is not enough to hold
on to emotionally to have you give a
[ __ ] about any of this to the point you
forget that it's a prequel like that's
the biggest thing i never once forgot
like you know wow that movie had the
effect of if i get pulled out i know
he's gonna live but i was so into it
that i forgot about it it never achieves
that effect and then you got so many
characters on top of that who are just
mainly there for plot like no one has a
character arc in this film no one has a
journey or a life lesson this is in the
harry potter world and that's what that
franchise did so well and why that has
such strong legs the bottom line is if
you're gonna watch a tail this sprawling
the visuals become you become numb to
them after a while they stop holding its
weight so i think it has every right to
be compared to them especially when this
franchise is so much about dumbledore
and less about the new characters
because the movie doesn't seem to even
try too much to make you really care
about them the main character who
actually has an arc is the character who
progressively becomes less interesting
throughout this franchise for me at
least ezra miller as credence he there
is so much importance placed on him
in all three of these movies and his
screen time becomes less and less and
less and this is arguably what he should
be the most important out of any three
films he's dumble snape now and he's
just such a bland character he's just so
boring he's the one with the most to do
emotionally he should be the most
emotionally complex and technically he
is you should be invested for the battle
over his soul though i still couldn't
get two shits about what credence is
going through in this movie there's just
something missing there's a detachment
there like just not quite there you know
yeah i mean for something that was
pitched as a five movie franchise i feel
like it's ended now yeah well yeah and i
feel like part of what has hampered it
past the first movie is it seems like
they tried to push too hard too fast to
get to those deathly hallows level
heights of importance and stakes and i
feel like they would have really
benefited from building these stories
out over time with a gradual sensibility
much like the harry potter films did
instead of trying to skip to that level
of importance and at this third
installment it does feel like they've
now corrected their course so that if
this does well they can continue but if
it doesn't they don't have to it's a
weird experience because while it was
more enjoyable than i expected it to be
i still can't help but feel like it is
not as magical as this film is clearly
seeking to be and when you're in the
camp of the harry potter world it should
be better that's just my personal
opinion i feel like it ought to be
better yeah i mean as somebody who's
been invested in harry potter for most
of my life i feel like it's easy to come
in and sound as though you have a big
set of expectations but really all i
want from any harry potter movie is to
feel that certain sense of warm but also
a little bit foreboding magic wonder and
i feel like since the first fantastic
beasts they have been kind of stumbling
around trying to find that and this
movie doesn't quite get there but it
gets closer than the previous one it
gets there in in little moments yeah
they're good set sequences like there's
one at this interesting prison involving
like scorpions that i thought was really
cool it was very fun it was a really fun
sequence and that's when the movie
actually decides to get a little kooky
and a little weird you know which i
think you also expect from a harry
potter and they haven't been doing quite
as much but alright guys fantastic
beasts and the secrets of dumbledore do
you want two more of these leave your
thoughts down below
subscribe click that bell hit that like
button we'll catch you guys soon
[Music]